[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
hello
[Music]
man I haven't heard this intro music in
a long time dude it's good
hello
what up people
[Music]
how we doing today
I really need to get a Hello emote
I do that every time
how we doing today people
happy
what day is it today
Monday I think yeah Monday
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello
I am so ready for this
[Music]
I am so incredibly
[Music]
happy to be playing this game
this this is the Dark Souls 3 is the
game I have the most experience in I
would say
like I know what's going on with this
game big time
[Music]
big time
let's go a new game
new game can't hear myself in there we
doing a strength build we're gonna watch
this real quick though
I was thinking twin blades it's the best
it's the best
I have not seen this cutscene in such a
long time
in venturing North
the pilgrims discover the truth of the
old yes sell sword meme blades
[Music]
and the Lords go without Thrones
this intro is so freaking epic I love it
why didn't Elden ring have a cinematic
intro
they spent all their money making this
one right threatened
hi Kyle
[Music]
Raves
[Music]
I'm not gonna lie to the Quality looks
like [ __ ]
I think it's pixely
quality's good it's pixely though
parents Undead Legion they are best
Watchers
so freaky cool looking
and the reclusive lord of the profaned
capital goddess
Zone the Giants
oh
[Applause]
damn bro
only what's up chimpanzee
the Lords will abandon their Thrones
[Music]
and the unkindled will rise
[Music]
foreign
this was my first Souls game ever
[Music]
oh
okay by the way guys I have like
two
I think I have over 2 000 hours in this
game just so we know just so you're
aware of that
uh haven't played it in a while like I
think close to a year I haven't even
touched this game considering Elden ring
but I used to play this game Non-Stop
I love this scam
I'm pretty sure the character I last
made last year was named big dick
swangin
hmm I want to do twinblade
the the mercenary you just get the twin
blades right off the rip
that's what I I'm gonna I'm gonna do
that
but what uh what's our name
#bds exactly
big dick swanging dude
I'm like I'm not kidding you guys we
could beat this game today
that's how much experience I have in
this game I think we can beat the main
game and then we can do DLC tomorrow
because that'll just take way too long
but we'll see
[Music]
we could definitely beat main game in
one day
just because I know where everything is
I know how to get strong really fast
uh well actually I don't know where
upgrade materials are materials are I
don't really remember
Smith
Hugo grundleberg
[Music]
John Souls the sequel
Ben Dover senior okay
I kind of like uh
uh Hugo grunderberg
grundleberg let's go with that that's
funny
Hugo
grundleberg that kind of reminds me of
Von Winkle shirt from uh
bloodborne
Hugo grundleberg
I don't really care what my boy looks
like to be honest with you that's good
did I swear this is the game that like
getting a blessing at the beginning just
does not matter at all
do I have any like saved appearances
no all right what else
I'm gonna go right into it no I'm not
playing online
[ __ ] that
ding
Elder Ring's the first one I finished I
played this game when it released it was
my first Souls game
and then I never looked back
nah we don't need the master key to be
honest
you think I want you guys to invade me
it's on PC
yeah I think PVP is mostly alive in this
game
considering it was offline for like a
year right
okay let me fix some stuff
I need to move the goal right there
um
Pat are you high enough
no I could probably move you up a bit
there we go
considering this is all different from
bloodborne
black firebomb equals upgrade materials
at pickle pee
pump my rump
what's uh 60fps is is quite nice guys
can I up my res oh heck yeah
okay
we are maxed out
actually [ __ ] motion blur you're trash
get out of my game
oh
guys 60 frames per second how does that
feel
um
yes please
oh yeah we can upgrade these very
quickly
okay how's the sound do I sound okay is
the game too loud
I gotta remember how to play this game
I remember now
sounding good
lit
excuse me sir
[ __ ] you
stream is only 144p
that's on your end my guy
go to the [ __ ] settings idiot sorry
that was mean
that was mean I didn't mean to be that
mean
oh yeah what up bro
can I stagger this guy
if I hit him enough times
no eating no oh
oh
here we go
are we gonna have to play God of War
Kyle
before the new game comes out
okay not bad
I didn't die to it I mean I feel like
that's pretty good
yeah we're staying we're about to fight
gun deer that's all he ever talks about
this is the mercenary
we only picked this class for the twin
blades
yeah is anyone else having quality
issues
yeah I think it's scales with decks
I'm not I don't remember
the [ __ ] out of my way
oh
gate
give me that tit Shard baby let's go
ready for this ready for this [ __ ]
can't get me
you can't get me you kidding me bro
damn this is so sick
like this reminds me of Elden ring so
much but like if this was Elden ring
we'd be like we could go over there
but in this game you can't
even hit him here
can't even hit him here
he's got covered
literally covered bruh
yeah strafing
not good
that was my fault
thought he'd stagger
no cap
there we go
what
project
I don't remember the timings dude
heck just happened though
firebomb
okay I don't think I've ever seen that
attack in my life
if I die to gundir I swear to God
here
oh please
okay I'll stop memeing
I've actually died to gun deer that is
sad that is sad if you haven't played
this game before you don't know how sad
that is
holy [ __ ]
that is painful
oof
no more trolling
foreign
[ __ ]
wow
I'm so bad bro
not again
what is my character doing what
what the hell
what am I stuck on
what's happening oh God
oh God
why is he walking like this what
happened to my camera
I just want to get here okay there we go
I got cursed
that cursed by the gun deer
I don't know what I did to have that
happen I have never seen that before
ever
hi Esther
yeah I was I was moonwalking my victory
obviously
clearly clearly
I was drifting
imagine I could like speed run like like
moonwalk all the way to lothric like
that I don't think that would save us
any time at all
like ever
that was so dumb I love it
oh God you are this you are the best I
love you into the bonfire I miss you
fire keeper
yeah you are
I tend to the flame yeah you do pretend
to thee
the Lords have left their Thrones and
must be delivered to them
to this end hmm
very well level me up mommy then touch
the darkness Within me I will touch yeah
the darkness
Souls
[Music]
pick Rick praise the son the pickle Lord
has returned the hardest Of All Bosses
lamal how you been my man I've been good
pickle I had a great weekend I hope you
did too thank you for the five dollars I
appreciate it very much
praise the sun pickle Lord
they have seven level levels off the rip
I like that X
wait
[Music]
that's what I'm doing start
farewell I shouldn't someone said I need
to turn on vsync is that true
oh let me put this here
pop my rump
if you don't know what that is you know
add a context pump my rump is really
weird
really weird
I'm gonna get rid of this Shield because
I don't need it
we got mommy Chulo
actually granny Chulo
Andre makes a return well a newcomer I
see
I am Andre I serve at this Shrine as a
humbles with forging weapons
you're in search of the Lords of Sindhu
I trust goddamn right a doilson journey
I'd wager it's kind of just like
eldering guys if you don't know
let me Smith your weapons I Am A Smith
such as my purpose God I love you okay
we need one more tit Shard we need a lot
of tit shards
I know pretty pretty be careful yep it's
huge
so basically this is just like Alden
ring if you haven't played Dark Souls 3
before we got all these Thrones Lords of
Cinder that we have to bring their
[ __ ] head back to their throne
and it's cool
to to mend the fire basically
so just like doubling you got to kill
certain demigods to I guess like yeah to
mend the Elden ring it's kind of the
same thing
why are people complaining that my
stream is blurry I have some of the best
quality streams on YouTube
quit complaining go to your settings and
fix it yourself it's not always my fault
okay
okay just kidding that's my bad
it's actually not
you can fix it what the [ __ ] okay I
dropped my computer my controller oh we
got our sad boy ah another one roused
from the sleep of death it's not my
fault well you're not alone we unkindled
are worthless
die right you can tell I'm very hyper
today it gives me conniptions
and they'd have us seek the Lords of
Cinder and return them to their molding
Thrones
and we are talking true Legends with the
metal to limp the fire
fit to lick their boots
don't you think
ah typical Souls game
that NPC laughs at us at the end [ __ ]
you
let's go to lothric or actually
yo I wonder if I can still do the glitch
hold on
or not the glitch the skip
[Music]
hold up
I gotta take all my clothes off ignore
that okay
put that away free skip
literally first try
oh my God
first freaking try dude
one attempt
boom
we up here
you
you
and me
me
Pro Gamer
oh
gamer dude
okay what do I drop I think I dropped a
fire bomb right actually like legit
leave selected oh wait yeah yeah
um
uh
wait
Discord
did I do the wrong thing
uh-oh
oh okay cool
you
I did the wrong thing didn't I
mean
bro you kidding me
literally an l s this Shard rip an S
this Shard another one wait isn't that
what I get
I don't remember
I goofed we'll come back
we're gonna get this though
I thought leave meant like leave the
menu man
bruh
okay why are why are you guys telling me
that the quality is bad
actually it's like two of you never mind
let me put all my stuff back on
excellent
let's go to lothric
foreign
do I have a bone nope
wait
wait
okay yes it can very much be your
internet
which is good what needs Smith in this
day
uh reinforce Estus flask excellent a lot
perfect
ly pumped me wrong
[Music]
it's the shock of going from bloodborne
to DS3
nice okay high wall of lothric let's go
[Music]
my ISP is giving me the correct download
speed and I can see the amazing quality
of the stream okay
damn this game looks good
yeah we're gonna do the DLC for sure
something
yeah if you guys haven't played this
game you should play this game
for real
for real dude
leave me alone sir
you lost 24 million souls in this game
can we get a lull at Rick everyone LOL
minus 24 mil
just kidding thank you pickle
appreciate you man
let me grab these real quick
um I don't know how much I've lost
maybe I I have no idea I've never even
like considered
I've never lost souls
that's the answer I've never died in
this game
ignore the death to gundier
[Applause]
no
ignore the one death to gun deer somehow
what up Brian
hey we running fam
it's speed run
that kind of hurt not gonna cab
okay can I still do this part
nope
nope nope nope
that's right I can't die I don't die
leave me alone I want to hit the bonfire
you can't see me
okay like apparently you can
dude no cap
I actually thought it was bloodborne for
a second and I was gonna get healing
back
no I'm not gonna try dancer
what was this guy doing dude
okay
sir
you're just like the lothric knights at
Stormville
[ __ ]
foreign
this is not good
there we go
not good
backstab no backstab
no don't do that I don't know what that
is
man literally has an ash of War
this sucks
foreign
get the heck out of my town you're
coming with me
uh yeah I would say Elden ring all of
the bosses that you fight against are
extremely fast and there's like not very
many windows of attack
if I'm being dead ass with you
um but they're like the games are
different in their own ways you know
what I'm saying
ah guys Melania is totally fair right
totally fair boss
you [ __ ]
foreign
non-bull [ __ ] boss right guys
it's like I know what I'm doing
number I don't really need this stuff in
here to be H TDH
I have grown to like fighting Melania as
well I still think she's [ __ ]
foreign
I gotta go talk to Grandma leave me
alone
because we need the flag
ah the wait has to be long unkindled one
I am Emma High Priestess of lothric
Castle
Chardon there
you will not find the Lords of Cinder
here they have left gone to their
Journey homes
energy at the
at the castle
head to the bottom of the high wall
forge on through the Great Gate and
raise this Banner to proceed
epic okay can do can do this farewell
gift is for you
I love this game too nandas
I have like 2 000 hours
it's been a long time though it's been
like a year since I played no
no guys I am not gonna do
I am not doing dancer yet we are not
ready for dancer at all okay
if you want me to be here for like two
hours
then fine
how you doing it though
unless
just kidding
I was gonna be like 100 bucks and I'll
do it
but nah that's lame
I would though
yeah Granny's a [ __ ]
the orphan under leveled why not dancer
dude I am 20 minutes in this game I was
like 12 hours into
bloodborne my guy
very big difference I will turn up the
music for gun deer
yes we'll play sakiro after we beat this
game we I think we can beat this game
today and tomorrow and then we'll play
Sakira
[Music]
three
bro
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you guys know I had someone in my chat
the other day go like dude I can't get
passport what the [ __ ] man
Lowell just kidding
I died to him like 50 times my first
time through this game don't worry about
it you'll get there
I died to gun deer like 25 times in my
first playthrough of this game
praise the view praise the view
oh that is the meme song isn't it
I didn't even think about that
aren't these guys from Dark Souls 1 like
these same exact dudes that take me to
uh
Ann Orlando I'm pretty sure
it's a very different place they take me
to
go kill a tree
let's go
you guys ready to murder a tree
[Music]
no no no no no no
let's go get our boy
yeah yeah we'll go level up we'll go do
all the [ __ ] I just gotta do some stuff
real quick
yes screw nature
dogs in this game are pretty bad just so
you guys know
but they're pretty annoying
in the Green School
grant me death
undo my shackle me every day
oh
a champion of Ash as I live and breathe
to be in your presence is a great honor
I am Joel of londor the program as you
can see only
somehow I failed to die as was ordained
well perhaps my calling lies elsewhere
why do you guys want me to kill him
champion of Ash
how does the idea of taking me into your
service strike you oh yeah we'll fight
nameless King I was once we'll find
every boss
surely I can be of use
yeah he goes back he can give us levels
and stuff
right hello
yeah I'm gonna accept it I don't know
why you guys want me to kill him so bad
hello I should be dead
yet you have granted me purpose a new
I yo love Londo do solemnly swear myself
to you
yeah I'm not gonna lie we probably won't
use them
he's like don't you have to die to even
get the levels from him I don't die
so that's gonna pretty much make him
useless
so like whatevs
these dogs are just rolling out here
God
[ __ ] get to the switch
bonfire's lit
get it got it get him out of here how
are they hurting me [ __ ] you
we annihilated for it first try I
actually died to gun deer I don't want
to talk about it look at that giant up
there
shooting arrows
well you should shoot arrows right yeah
yeah
I think that's really cool
I am not leveling luck I will level luck
if we want to do an ornery straight
sword run
um I don't want to kill Henry though I
want to do requests so we're going to do
that instead
let's go level though
what are you getting
um whatever you guys want
what up Lewis what up handgun
good morning
what the [ __ ] okay I fell whoops
to use these [ __ ]
wrong thing again
soul of the Boreal Valley
a nice 2K
we're gonna level this [ __ ] up plus one
sell sword let's go
um don't I put the raw gem on it yeah I
do for now I do
and then
oh I can go get the other one
and then we're gonna go level
doing cell sword build
you welcome home mushrooms oh have you
guys ever done this where you um
you talk to her
but you do like
I don't know a jump for joy
and she'll like laugh
I really like that
speak very well then
[Music]
um get that the 20 vigor
[Music]
level Baker
is that in bloodborne I thought we tried
it and she didn't do anything
also we got more fire bombs so I'm gonna
go get the other thing from
pop my rump
load load
hello
um we started 40 minutes ago
why is this closed okay there we go
what the [ __ ]
what's this
don't even care
first try again
I'm a gamer
Pro gamer Pro Gamer
okay I will not discard it this time
I will pump thy rump
firebomb leave
there
our guy's body is just gross
large tit Shard let's go
we're gonna need that later
foreign
tits
I actually made that jump Twice first
try
now I don't mean to toot my own horn
but that's pretty [ __ ] cool
did I find a bone no I'm about to go
find a bone actually here we go
[Music]
I already have the serpent ring
hey boys we're gonna go beat up a
[ __ ] tree
some [ __ ] ass tree
this place is gross
yo
what is that moveset remind you of
the [ __ ] imps from Elden ring
how old are you guess
how old do you think I am chat
that's this shark
oh I should probably do this there we go
yep I'm 13 years old
foreign
there we go now we can level again oh
I'm gonna need y'all to cut it out
stop it
foreign
s bro
need that later oh God
it's your birthday tomorrow I'm turning
27 let's go dude
I am hitting this bonfire real quick
you told us already yeah but a lot of
people don't know
this guy does suck he's actually hard
I like his color though
[ __ ]
but happy birthday
to Michael
what is he doing I thought he's gonna
throw that knee please kill this other
guy please do it do it [ __ ] bro
what is this
oh it's healing him bro I'm out
nope
actually we might be able to kill him
with the arrows here
remember that giant I was telling you
about
that's where he's shooting
I didn't make friends with him yet
thank you
sir get out of the way I have to go kill
your tree
[Applause]
my goodness
all right
okay
do I remember how to properly fight the
tree
I think I do
I'm gonna go grab this bonfire over here
too real quick
it's so much closer
oh that's right we hit his nut sack
we hit his nut sack that's right
that's right
he has other bubbles too
oh you have to go down over there that's
right
it's hard to remember all this stuff hot
boy
excellent
and bonfire
yeah it is kind of like taking down a
mausoleum
I have if if this Strat still works I
can like bait the tree into doing the
same attack over and over again
which makes him like literally easy as
[ __ ]
otherwise he can like one shot you
because you know he's a giant tree
let's do it
yeah I don't like
God
the level design around here is freaking
awesome
you mean uh
the nameless King beep bop
okay let's go over here I think I have
to hit his hand I
[Music]
think
got his hand
okay
get those balls boys
just get those balls
[Music]
yummy
that's what we want
thank you
okay I have to stand a certain distance
[Music]
there we go
foreign
I hit these no
foreign
[Music]
he actually just laid on top of me I
have never seen that attack before ever
in 2000 hours I have never seen him drop
on his back like that that's funny
do that uh we probably could have gone
without the music being on full blaster
probably
okay let's go back
because we can level again
we can do that
you can pop this [ __ ]
yeah dude he laid his ball sack on me
were you guys not you know
you don't like that
[Music]
I don't like that
nah we don't like that we don't
[Music]
we don't maybe not from the tree
[Music]
combine Hots design
okay
um actually let me check my sword real
quick
real quick
then
you show item info
entry requirement blah blah blah
[Music]
looks like nothing there are no
attribute bonuses okay welcome host
pretty sure it's just Dex
kinda right
more so strength
it's kind of the same oh it is because I
made it raw
oh
we'll work around it
May the Flames guide
thy heart
I still need two more wow
[Music]
that's what I wanted to do
okay
is it sharp gem I thought it was raw
I think you're right
wait is it refined
is that sharp
we could do that
I remember using raw but I think that
was just for the start
[Music]
yeah we want
we want refined and then we can scale it
no we're gonna we're gonna go with shark
we need to get the coal we're fine we're
[Music]
good
let's go
uh there's a fire truck in my
okay it's going the other way I'm like
hello
Rebel not there we want to go here
and then we're gonna run through the
worst area in the game
Imo
white literally Sprint through this area
fast as humanly possible once they pass
nah you don't see me shut up
that dog is tweaking out man he is
having a bad time
he has no idea what's good what the heck
is this dog doing dude all right
whatever let's go
la la
speedrun Strat I want him off me I ain't
dealing with it
the door will be open and they will be
gone
speedrun Strat
let's talk to this guy
another one of those unkindled are you
all you faceless Undead behaving as if
you deserve respect
no matter
heed my words Melania if you've any
sense
you go find a coffin to huddle up inside
heed my words in this land of Hollows
you're like a frail Maiden on the front
lines
if like the others you're fool enough to
play the champion
then go on ahead
traips right past the abandoned church
you'll face death
and it won't be pretty
enough death to leave you broken
Time After Time
I feel so motivated now
so I feel so motivated to do what I'm
supposed to do now thanks man
you guys ready for this reveal
the best reveal in gaming
oh
it's our boy
what up Onion Man hmm
[Music]
uh oh nightbot gotcha hmm
oh oh
pardon me I was absorbed in thought oh
yes dude I am ziegvert of Katarina
to be honest I'm in a bit of a pickle
pickle Rick have you ever walked near a
white birch only to be struck by a great
Arrow
yeah well if I'm not mistaken they come
from this Tower
whoever it is I'm sure I can talk some
sense into them
but I have to find a way up and that's
just the trouble this lift only goes
down you'll see him only goes down
well that doesn't get me anywhere
hmm
well if it only goes down
yeah I see your pickle it does only go
down that's kind of weird
how do we get it back up oh well would
you look at that
this goes up see ya idiot
quite the pickle
white the pickle
who are you
who are you your best friend I help
anytime thank you
I help anytime
thank you
now he'll help us
in a area later on
where does he shoot at I think he shoots
over here
yeah he shoots it like that courtyard I
think
I help anytime
now we're going to go down and we're
gonna hear
hmm
not gonna go there yet this is more
efficient I swear
I help anytime
by the way this [ __ ] down here I don't
fight it
I don't fight this guy
nope
uh
deep themed game no what's that
I have like 2 000 hours in this game
base cat
bye [ __ ]
so let me open the door Jesus Christ
God damn
[ __ ]
just wanted to open the door
eat
s
you
not even worth fighting
all right let's go
or actually
I need to go help Secret
we can fight a demon together
so I'm actually have to go back
I have to go back here which is kind of
annoying because I have to run past
everything but at least the doors open
but at least I can go back here without
having to do the whole run through again
but we're gonna help him
no I have not watched berserk
I keep hearing that like
the anime isn't very good
however
where am I going right now the wrong way
is the answer to that
apparently like reading it's better or
something I don't know
a little Amber
are the movies good
there's a rumor of a game that was
originally Dark Souls 4 but it's now its
own thing it would have eyes of C
bloodborne
what
oh wait I wanted to go on that piss
foreign this is not good Fellas
this is what I wanted to avoid
no
no stay
bye bye
wait there's rumors of Dark Souls 4
really like a dark souls 4 game
oh don't disappear like that you had me
downright worried that sounds cool Kirby
thanks to you an epiphany has struck me
squared in the head
I've unraveled the riddle of this
inscrutable lift you have it was very
complicated
very complicated indeed on some days I
begin to doubt myself I went up the
tower so I thought then somehow ended up
here I'm not exactly sure what happened
anyhow do you see that that humongous
Beast
I know coward and I have a steady hand
but that thing makes my skin crawl
how now think twice before you go down
that road
nah let's just do it
should have waited hey
[Music]
no you should have waited I did well
it's too late now let's get it
I think word of the Knights of Catalina
right by your side
ah
let's go
[ __ ] you demon
you a [ __ ]
nerd
[Music]
oh we're down we got we gotta sit down
that was too much
that was quite a performance I'm pretty
sure I did everything my guy go ahead
we unkindled must put our duties first
but for the moment we were toast to me
yes we do
my sword and our Victory together
long may the sunshine boys let's use
that actually switch
and let's have a toast with our boy
long may the Sun gone
let's go
hi buddy
I'm going to have myself a little nap
gotta take it [ __ ] now dude really
after a nice toast
what were you guys saying 4chan is more
reliable always the the leaks of Dark
Souls 4 from 4chan
yeah
is that reliable
I don't know about that
I don't know about that people
um I think a Homeward mode is just the
easiest we'll do
grind I think we can level
and give that to the crow that's right
where'd she go there we go
the dude said he leaked Elden ring so
perhaps
wasn't eldering leaked like years before
it came out
never hurt in this game
oh well I should have won
May the Flames guide thee so they
someone else said in chat earlier that
band Kai Namco said that Elden rings
only the beginning
damn cool
I don't think I got another one of these
let's go
[Music]
oh we're here now we're literally gonna
run through this area
I'm sure I'm forgetting a lot of things
guys but I don't have to get everything
it's okay we're gonna be fine
kind of got that vibe
is Iowa storm made a video about it
gotcha
I don't know
I'd like to hear about concrete things
when it comes to that
hiring a bunch of new personnel
well good they can afford it
free
I am ornery of a store
foreign horse
oh hello how do you do oh I love these
two I am Henry of astora unkindled like
you
this is Horus
a friend and traveling companion
are you two in search of the Lords of
Cinder
we are well along the road of sacrifices
below us is the crucifixion Woods her
armor is sick turn on the flooded Woods
in her arm is the Dark Souls 1 armor
Undead Legion
further yet is the Cathedral of the deep
we seek the Cathedral Home of the Grim
Aldrich I think if eldering made DLC it
won't be open worldly it'll be like a
whole other area for us to explore the
next time we cross paths
one may find the other in a time of need
Elite night set yeah all the Flames
guide your way
yeah I hope nothing bad will happen to
the characters that we meet in this game
that don't try to kill us like that's
that's usually usually it all ends well
right guys oh yes Horus
he's not very talkative
but don't think you love him
he's an upstanding kind-hearted Knight a
fine partner for this grueling Journey
without his help I would have cursed
this onerous Duty long ago
we are well along the road of sacrifices
beyond the flooded Woods lies far and
keep lesion
her storyline goes to who Aldritch now
but we are both Seekers of Lords
the next time we cross paths one may
find the other in a time of need
May the Flames guide your way
we are well along the road of sacrifices
she's one of my favorite characters in
all the souls games she's cool
pretty sure I can marry her later right
kinda
well I don't marry her wait do I I don't
remember the questline we're gonna go
get a shield
I will do that when I go back pickle
Rick
[Music]
dude
[Music]
which tree is it I think it's this one
here we go crab
oh boy here we go
hey you guys ready for this
here's a strat on how to kill these guys
hang like right here
idiots
where's the guy who invaded me I'll do
the same thing
who invaded
where you at oh there you are
you went invisible invisible
oh
you
wizard okay
Pro Gamer time Pro Gamer here we go
and ow
[ __ ] ow
no you're bad fall fall thanks
laughs
idiots
okay let's go give our
I think it's a beer to the tree not to
the tree it's a pump of rump
oh we got this chick now
divinity
duties we each bear but one's duty is a
solitary affair
I doubt we've much to gain from
fraternization
blessing of the Moon upon your journey
I doubt we've muched a game from
fraternization yeah I have to join her
like Colt for her even care about me
right thank you
there's this
[Music]
it's German for victory Brews very well
then touch take note is sick word sick
word however you say his name uh is he
German
really got to get the sharp gem don't we
I wish I didn't make it wrong that's
okay
I gotta do the skip again
can I do it three times in a row first
try let's find out
have the way of the blue but I haven't
turned it on
or is it blue Sentinel
this
he is as German as one can be
I want to visit Germany I want to visit
most of Europe [ __ ]
couldn't do it
oh it's all falling apart
I was a Pro Gamer until now now it's
just embarrassing
there we go
oh it's Sentinel gotcha
this off then
you don't really matter
[Music]
you you pop my rump
why does she say pump my romp I find it
very odd
okay we are going to leave it not
discarded
very excited
armor of the Sun
oh [ __ ]
yes sir
with the crown
oh yeah
can I even praise the sun yet
no we'll find it
that's me me
damn nightbot's on one today
cooperation friends
it's still rolling good okay we're good
I legit just tried to jump like normal
I'm not gonna lie I have not played
Elden ring in like almost two weeks
that looks so good
look at me
don't say nothing okay
we are good travel to actually we can
get a lot of titanite shards here
actually
I'm not we're we'll be good on the
Covenants
okay
um
let me do this real quick
oh God
I love swamps
there's so much fun
me alone
[Music]
yeah where's the rest of the Summer sun
armor
have the dagger
one area
no big deal
no big deal
I really didn't need to go this far for
that
when a very different direction than
what I was expecting to do oh God
that's what we want
Hideki and his damn swamps dude
so I gave her a Homeward bone a giant
seed and a lightning urn gotcha
you're always barking I'm very upset
hey the fire truck's leaving
I hate those guys bro
uh [ __ ] I am lost okay there's the
entrance
I'm not huge on y'all Kirby it's okay
[ __ ] man
ow try to grab me grab me again
it's the hardest enemies in the game no
cap fine just [ __ ] kill me
Miyazaki and his [ __ ] swamps dude
yeah I died like right here so whatever
yep
I did die I did do the dying thing
three levels levels are not that big of
a deal in the game guys it's okay
calm down about telling me what to do
I am playing the game
first scene is a death scene dude it's
been an hour and 20 minutes
you forehead
foreign
perfect
all the cutscenes are the same right I
think
I'm gonna skip these
leave me alone
uh
this yeah the tree has a ton of weak
spots if you uh look for them
or that other guy
like click click click click click
foreign
thank you Hood I'm glad you enjoyed them
Bonk
probably pop an ember before we go in
there
sure if I can beat the abyss Watchers
like this
where was the uh the S this shard
did I already grab it
so remember I it's like around here
it's not that way
oh we can also go up here
ow
when you first ignite a bonfire is there
a little animation of the sorghini fix I
don't know
how long have you been streaming on
YouTube for
when did I start streaming on here like
three four months ago or five months ago
something like that
I streamed on Twitch for four years
I prefer YouTube much more than twitch
much much much more
personally
okay
I didn't oh I could have looked right
there Tommy I'm an idiot my bad
oh that's good ashes right wait I hear a
[ __ ]
God damn
I need that item I think
algorithm recommended me the stream and
you've earned a new sub let's go thanks
dude
glad you liked it
enough to sub
I'm doing the slowest route possible to
100 000 Subs but we are doing it
you guys will never know how old I am I
could be 13 years old I could be seven I
could be 105. you'll never know
he's gotta guess
Nikola is alive found his way to the
reverse time sending you back at the
prime and lands over the face of
demigods Peak power so we get to blow my
queen Act
hello I like that theory a lot
I'm 105 years old guys
believe it or not
I'm old as
piss dude
all right do I fight this guy
I'll leave it to chat do I fight this
guy or not
I'm pretty sure I'd die here like many
times
he gives me good items he gives me lots
of of Souls
[ __ ]
yeah I'm scared
look at this guy
foreign
I am an Esports
why was that so loud I am in Esports Pro
gaming Legend
so good at the video game
my ego inflated to a billion
next title YouTuber gets inflated ego
beating literal Dark Souls 1 boss
yeah
imagine lol in parentheses with an emoji
laughing emoji
is that the kind of videos you guys
watch
no okay
large titties
foreign yeah his animation like death
animation there was insanely loud
imagine
okay
Dragon Crest Shield
yeah I can buy tight Knights now right
with the ash I found
not even paying attention to you right
now little Skelly
foreign
heavy Jim
do we want that not really
all right we go back
what's funny is I'm not even good at
these games
you know what it is guys
this might be a
a weird take or a
a hot take
Souls games are easy
straight up
they're not hard
the people that think they're hard
are normies angels
Call of Duty players who don't know what
they're doing
and honestly they're just bad at the
game
I don't know why I do that every time
I'm on an elevator I always send it back
the other way for no reason at all
right let me go back because I think
there's some stuff we can do
I'm mostly kidding there guys but it's
kind of true
mostly kidding
I
thought I already talked to her whoops
Ashen one what woeful umbral Ash is this
sounds like you don't like my presence
dust stuff of a fool won't heal hello
where did stuff happen upon the stuff
tell me for the sport
I found it where I found it oh yes I see
clinging to lofty
drink everyone in this Shrine is so sad
come from one most foolish indeed
which thou not agree
[Music]
okay give me tits nice how many do we
need fashion one I can only go to plus
three of those two but we found a lot of
large bits as well
reinforce oh I already can
we need
five
we gotta buy five
[Music]
excellent
probably could have found them this is a
lot easier
let's rock and go plus four
and
didn't find one of those
[Music]
share my theory with you because you
were one of the few who also believe
Michael is alive
are there people who think Michael is
dead like dead dead I don't think so
you guys think that
20th okay
one EK
[Music]
see
Mexican hell
I think that's fine
I think Nicholas I think Michael is
alive
I think most people think that way right
we found a boner let's go
[Music]
like definitely still alive
we want to go here
foreign
I think he's being used heavily right
now but to what extent we don't really
know
oh 100 grimp so I I mean I died to ludax
gundir like 25 30 times in my first
playthrough everyone gets used to these
games the more you play these games the
better you get at them like the more you
understand what you're supposed to do
like I this was my first Souls game
um which I don't think is odd I think
Dark Souls 3 was the first Souls game
for a lot of people
more so Elden ring obviously right oh I
haven't equipped The Shield thank you
we grabbed it and never put it on
recall good call that this gives us more
stamina
um
so my like this was my first game and
I've heard a Dark Souls before I'd heard
of other games but I just never gave it
a chance
and then with dark souls 3 I was like
you know what I'm gonna give it a shot
died to gun deer 25 times and was like
dude I am trash what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] I was a Call of Duty player just
like I was saying I was a cop I was a
Cod player and I'm going from Cod to
this you're like what the hell am I
doing
and then I figured it out and now I've
played all the games
so
I think once you understand what these
games are they're the best games out
there
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
everything's so loud oh another lizard I
forgot you were here
foreign
help
help
I just I thought I was gonna glitch out
of the game right there with where my
camera was going oh my God
is the coal over here guys
is this where I find the twin blades
oh [ __ ] hell
[Music]
this is where I find another set of twin
blades isn't it
no it's the cold
get to the door
run run
no shot
[Music]
first playthrough I didn't know I could
upgrade so I got to the fire giant with
plus zero Uchi and Ripper Supply
and how was that
you're kind of insane for that dude wow
all right you guys ready for probably
one of the best boss fights in the game
you guys ready for this [ __ ]
hello
you guys not know oh God
Pro Gamer activated let's get this [ __ ]
these guys are so cool to me
they remind me of bloodborne characters
like the same type of fashion
[Laughter]
you know also sword coat and blood I
mean come on
[Music]
back it up
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
easy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so [ __ ] hard man I just got comboed
to no end right there oh my God
oh my God
oh my God
yo I'm not gonna lie I gotta turn down
the [ __ ] music dude it's so loud I'll
turn down one
you die great inference good comment
I did do that
imagine not even using the emote
couldn't be me
it's a little loud a little bit loud
all right let's try that again
non-embered up
[Music]
he date double hit me bro
[Music]
us
I love this game
[Music]
give me the third one man okay there he
is but he's gonna attack me
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
[Music]
no they killed my boy that quick
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I got this i got this
maybe not
[Music]
[Music]
damn you're fast
I'm triggered
his his little Pokey
his little Pokey dude staggered me and
then I rolled at the wrong time and the
timing was off that was so close
damn it
I got it though I know what moved the
bait out we got it this try
I have my jump button on the wrong on
the right button
foreign
which doesn't really matter like if you
prefer the other button then
that is your prerogative
try avoiding his attacks
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
mm-hmm
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh shot no shot no shot dude
come on
number four
he staggered me into a oh my God
he just staggered me
[ __ ]
as the worst thing that could have
happened
I had him on the ropes
oh that one hurt
that one hurt my soul
I could have farted on him and he would
have died
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
could not have been a better start
literally perfect
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bro
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
oh
we need to change the title to how to
get completely destroyed in Dark Souls
dude we've been on this for like 10
minutes
not even that
long
[Music]
third one came in quick
[Music]
get annihilated kid Jesus Christ okay
[Music]
[Music]
is so dumb I got caught on a rock
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
GG first try not even hard
I didn't even die I don't know what you
guys are talking about that was easy
let me piss people off by calling it
easy
real quick
we just make them mad
get them rolling
okay let's go back
dude the crystal Sage is actually
low-key hard as [ __ ]
do people not have social awareness
press one in chat if you think people on
the internet don't have social awareness
for the most part
I'd be throwing a one in there
myself
speak thine heart's desire
hey what am I leveling
I feel like I need more Health let's get
that to 25.
that's weak [ __ ] a little bit more
strength will help
yep one first try didn't die not a
single time
yep
I'm aware of all the socials
give coal
excellent Infuse
you guys said I want sharp right
I'm pretty sure it's Sharp you could
have it just go back
but I I think it's Sharp
Lord of Hollows ending that's okay
yeah sharp is best
[Music]
Batman
we need three more large titties
be on the lookout for some large titties
chat
our keys 20K I'm just looking real quick
sorry
[Music]
did we get yol's levels
we don't really need them to be honest
with you
I know I didn't mean to give you too
much
listen I give people [ __ ] when they give
me [ __ ]
it's all in good fun
what am I here for what am I doing what
am I here for what am I doing
home
we can go fight the uh
let's go fight the witch
do you guys like the witch boss
personally I do not
but we gotta do it
not one of my favorite boss fights in
the game
but it is a it's a little different
now
ah they really don't manual for the most
part it's actually true
[Music]
foreign
I could have killed her there damn that
would have been nice
get out of here
that might have been the fastest I've
ever beaten that boss ever that was nuts
was there a boss there guys
I couldn't tell it was so quick
[ __ ]
Winkle tits
another twinkle
I know there's like a really good armor
set down here too isn't it
it's right here
yeah Harold's pretty good
hey
[Music]
um
I mean do I just go back and level
could die here I guess oh yeah I forgot
about you what up bro
we gonna do this forever
there are
ashes of word from this in Elden ring
huh
you're dead
Paladin's ashes
is there an Estus shard back there
I don't remember
I thought it was up the hill
there isn't one over here is there
yes it is a solare monk I'm gonna change
the Hat though because I find it
slightly obnoxious
oh yes
I skipped two that's a shame
that's okay
I'm gonna go with what I know
if I need them later
nerd
he's kind of like nepheli a little bit
oh where I start throwing the sage I got
you that's okay
we'll live without it
you guys ready for these dogs to spawn
in my [ __ ] watch this there they are
there they are
there they are
look at them spawning inside of my ass
totally fair video game by the way
get me out of here Speed Run Strat
they actually have the dogs spawn behind
you
oh we can already do DLC huh
please bear witness to our results
for ariander I love the area ashes of
ariandel DLC is so cool
and obviously ring City's sick too
rush through to get large tits
point
we'll be okay we'll come back later is
he coming the [ __ ]
I'm not doing Frida right now y'all can
go [ __ ] off with that
so there is an Estus shard here I'll
grab that and then we'll go back level
upgrade
we'll do all the [ __ ] yeah we can't do
that now can't we
I missed that opportunity
my way
you hate the area I think it's awesome
wait the first DLC for bloodborne was
snowy too
you guys think we're gonna get a snow
level
but we already had a snow level in Eldon
ring didn't we
mountain tops
do you guys think that they're gonna add
when they make DLC for Elden ring or if
they do
just I like pissing people off just by
saying if they make DLC
for Elden ring because they might not
they probably will but
do you think they'll add content onto
the the map as we know it or do you
think we'll go somewhere completely
different
will be like sent into a painted world
kind of like that or whatever
yeah swap area
new area kind of like when we go to uh
Fair Missoula type of thing
there are two DLCs for for DS
there are two DLCs for Dark Souls 3.
that is correct there is ashes of
Arendelle
and then there is uh
the ring City
ew Bots EU
yes
DLC will be Elder ring too
I think you're right
[Music]
I I personally believe they don't like
making sequels
well not sequels
but they like DLC
I don't know man it's we'll get what we
get
I would love DLC obviously
May the flame yeah I think that's all I
can do
so throwing some time traveling that
would be cool too
we'll get something man we'll get
something
[Music]
final boss will be Godwin there's a lot
of like bosses that people are throwing
out there that I'm like why would we
fight them
like think about mikola I have I can't
think of a reason why mikola would want
to fight us
uh before everything happens so like if
we are thrown back in time
because Nicholas seems like a sweetie
you know what I mean
we killed his sister I mean if we're
thrown back in time
honestly his sister tried to kill us
okay that's
that's pretty clear
but he might not care
um what's another one
I don't think radon would just try to
kill us
boner
okay the giant should be helping us
there we go
let's go let's go let's go
go fight the Dickens of the deep
I open this here no I can't
bleed
bleed build bleed build
what was a melania's teacher's name
again
none of them seem very artillery
um
morgot Moog
Melania I would I would say wanted to
kill us
where Don was out of his [ __ ] mind
obviously
right guard's out of his mind
um I don't want to deal with that we're
doing this
Blind Swordsman
I mean it's pretty clear that like
Melanie is blind too right
um I believe something drops on my head
if I grab that item and it's not even
worth so Bonk
yi yi
we'll take shortcuts as we get them
yeet
I believe we have to open this door
do
I wish a brewery was a big boss
yeah
I think uh
well
I don't know
there's just so many routes that they
could go
in making DLC I really wonder what
they're gonna decide why did I do that
I thought I could jump off in time
I mean why would the glomide queen want
to fight us too
what the [ __ ]
he was standing up
Lloyd's ring
ah
bully bully bully
Sawyer
go back up I want to fight this guy
alone
mimic
get him out of here
foreign
who else is here in 2022 what are you
talking about bro it's 2016.
2016.
I think there is a strong possibility
that the
Elder ring doesn't have DLC
and they just make another game
like not Elden Ring 2 right away but
they'll have another game and then
they'll make Elden Ring 2 eventually
that's just my
opinion
shoulders back back stab
this [ __ ] guy bro
oh Elden ring DLC in two months
confirmed huh
confirmed
I'll believe it when I see it
okay where's the elevator
it's not that way is it
it's this way
leave Kirk alone Kirk invaded me
you know another Bankai Namco game that
we should play are the little nightmares
games this month I think if you guys
haven't played little nightmares one and
two
they're two of my favorite games they're
incredibly good
uh in Dark Souls 3 if you find an item
you can
Kill by the size of the glow if it's
important
in elvenaring you find normal crafting
materials marked as important with a
purple glow
yeah that is kind of weird that's a good
point
that is kind of strange
way was even necessary
could they expand on Dark Souls
personally I don't think so
shut up Gail
personally I don't think so
all right let's go
what's in the corner
foreign
I got that in my bedroom what
huh
let's go level
we really need Elden ring DLC to fight
equally to bloodborne
I mean
I don't think they need to Eldon ring is
like Dark Souls one two it's like four
Dark Souls four five six bloodborne 2
all combined together like I know we all
played it and we all beat it and we want
something new but dude Elder ring is
[ __ ] huge with content you know
it's massive already
very well then touch the darkness Within
Me
yes Mommy
okay farewell I shouldn't one
Miracle Wilt build I'm kind of using an
OP build aren't I
it's okay what other game would you
recommend to someone that's only played
Elden ring this game
Elden ring is very much like uh Dark
Souls 3 here
very much so
travel
um and then I can just go down there
perfect
hello
it's the from software combo meal
shut up Gail
pickle Ricks
together
I want to see you beat nameless King
[ __ ] to mitter and slave nightgale all
first try pickle Rick believes in you
all right if I can beat all those bosses
in one try
what do I get
you know what I'll tell you guys what I
want
I want your unconditional love
is that enough
and a high five maybe a hug
I would like a hug too
there's a summon for this
I'm gonna use them just because I've
never actually used a summon for this
fight that's pretty cool also Rick thank
you for another five dollars I don't
know why you
do this so much but I appreciate you
oh and Audrey helps too okay let's go
you already have that name something
else I don't know if I already have that
bro
Joy
you're always barking a lot he's not
happy today
I might have to go get joy and bring her
downstairs
he's kind of nutty
beat up the glowy ones
[Music]
wow
okay
where's grandpa
Grandpa gonna come out there we go
[Music]
great job Henry
and you too Horus
JoJo let's stop barking all right I'm
gonna go get joy real quick I'm gonna
bring her downstairs I will be right
back
okay
Joy has joined us
because she is very upset
with somebody outside
I've been listening to you for ages and
just noticed it's not a YouTube video
hi YouTube
Joy chat says hi
yes
is there anything else in here
I think so
it's usually something you say on Twitch
say hi to YouTube
okay so now we gotta go uh down into the
Joy God damn
God come here
Joy come here right now
foreign
Joy is not happy right now
I got the butts
okay
none of you guys press those do you
when the Bots come up
dude my mods are either here or they're
not
[Music]
a buck you press all the time
I'd recommend not doing that
as a rule of uh rule of thumb
Joy I need you to take a nap okay
there's this a bunch of people at our
door
does it not support the streams no not
at all
I have no they're just Spam Bots
[Music]
okay I'm actually kind of do I not have
any other Esther shards
[Music]
no I'm Banning them not my mods
okay I had one
that's cool
I know I'm living in L but there's a
limits
yeah like using a site like that yeah
that's each their own
all right
we need to go to down under
so we go Abyss Watchers
[Music]
um I just call them spam Bots I don't
think of them as uh that word that I
probably can't say on stream
[Applause]
huge versus that guy
I would be sad if they ever fought
okay Joy's gonna try and take a nap guys
I'll try and take a nappy
damn what happened chimpanzee
I think I have to kill this guy for a
large tit right
you scare me though
bye bye
is the item literally all the way down
there I can see it on the bottom of the
screen
are you kidding can I quit out
and it'll be there
you're the 1v1 a Black Widow in Your
Shower
that is very stressful I'm sorry you had
to deal with that
this item better be [ __ ] up here bro
or I don't know
I'm gonna be
I mean here's his body
no item
pain
pain
I think we need that
white got white like black widow spiders
in your shower that sounds not fun at
all
isn't Andre down here somewhere chat
Bots have feelings too I'm pretty sure
they don't and that's kind of the point
you live in the desert that makes more
sense
I lived in Arizona for a while so I
understand
there's two I forgot
two
[Music]
to do
seven seven wait wouldn't honorary be
right here
right
have you played Elden ring yet no I
heard it's good though
you talk to her at halfway Fortress
I'm pretty sure I did
or was that a different area
season Firelink first she goes to fire
link
really
these guys get back up
that was a sapphire link
I talked to her at Firelink after
deacons
we'll definitely go find her
is her questline is cool
let's go down here
we can let the Skelly ball kill these
guys
die you foul wizard
[ __ ] dude
get back here wizard
Matt's a boner shard
all right
now
big question here guys
big question whoa
now would you all say
that the honeymoon phase of Elden ring
has worn off right
we're all not looking at it with bright
eyes
thinking it's you know maybe it is the
best thing ever but
you can still think this way but now
that the honeymoon phase is over
what would you give Eldon ring out of
10.
zero at it like you know
typical
10 scale
what would you give it
[Applause]
a hundred
that's pretty far above 10.
really like it
nine
eight seven pretty much everything above
a seven right which is pretty damn good
nerds
you give it a one that's funny
I want a silly large tit
he doesn't have that much replayability
I don't know about that dude it has a
ton of replayability
maybe not the replayability you like
though right
depends if DLC is good
[Music]
I I don't know this just think of uh
take uh
take DLC out of the equation like what
you have right now what would you give
it out of 10.
no DLC
I don't think I get anything cool from
this guy so I'm not gonna fight him
this little guy gives me some gem I
don't care about
foreign
[Music]
too that's good that's good
yeah I don't understand the argument
that Elden ring doesn't have
replayability
that don't make no sense to me
rip skellies
without DLC 8.5 it's got bloodborne
level DLC nut
best game of all time I got you
like Lorena Lakes
oh you have to do Henry before one year
okay we'll go back
I'll uh is there a bonfire down this way
I think there is
I get right now I give Eldon ring like
an 8 out of ten
hey you guys want a way to cheese this
demon right here watch this
oh [ __ ] I didn't think I'd get hit with
fire
watch watch we're gonna go around the
corner
the mimic will go fight the demon
unless it dies in half a [ __ ] second
like a noob
Black Blade though that's kind of cool
where's my boy Sigmund
Sigmund
foreign
what are you doing sir
you fatty
what's this game Elden ring DLC
imagine
how mad do you think I would get if I
titled this stream Elven ring DLC
oh Witch's Ring
forget what that does
okay I thought you had an arrow in your
hand sir
sir
this is a Wendy's
please get back in the drive-through
this is all Wendy's
this is Lego Dark Souls
I would be livid I'm sorry
when did they release DLC like six
months ago
you're pretty far behind my guy
all right let's go find Henry
if there's a DEX ring I definitely want
that okay where is she
oh hello Henry
you bought you
oh thank you metal I appreciate that oh
and Forest oh can we meet again
looks so cute memory of a store
I'm well pleased to see you safe
we reached the Cathedral of the deep
but aldrich's coffin was empty
the Manita must have left for his
trip the little doll in the empty coffin
told me
Aldridge is said to hail from
an ancient fabled city
a pilgrim told me that the city lies
Beyond fair and keep
and so becomes our destination
[Music]
aldrich's honest home is irofilm in the
Boreal Valley an ancient fabled city
a pilgrim told me that the city lies
Beyond farron keep
and so becomes our destination
aldrich's honest for pilgrimed and sober
what does Horace say
good talk oh that's where we get it
[Music]
wait are you guys saying Metal's funnier
than I am
press one and chat if you think Metal's
funnier than me
not sure
not true at all
[Music]
bro
[Music]
you know what you all are
y'all are a bunch of simps
don't worry so am I
[Music]
bought simp-like Behavior
I understand
May the Flames God I love it when she
tells me to Let the Flames guide me I
just love that [ __ ] bro what
let me reinforce a weapon we don't need
that weapon we need a large we need one
more large titty be careful one more
Uno large to Toto
simply telling the truth
no metal and I are not in a relationship
big old fat new
okay where are we going
we've talked to Henry so now we can I
fight one year now did we do enough
okay chimpanzee I see you I see you
what else oh yeah I have to find her in
the catacombs obviously
uh
um
oh yeah Horus isn't smoldering Lake
that's right yeah there's a lot we got
to do down here actually
easiest way to get to her is from the
abyss Watchers again
talk to honoring the catacombs to
locations
[Applause]
I'm not your sister I'm a dude clearly
hello
dollar High
on life
Ion Life
I killed this guy now for its hit shard
I would be a pretty cool Uncle please
don't fall off again
wow a regular tight night shard
it's like picking up a Ritz cracker on
the ground that has a bite out of it
at this point
[Music]
we were asking chat how old they think I
am earlier
I told him I'm 105 years old
wow he's so skinny it just goes right
past him sick
foreign
listen coming from a guy who's almost
out of his 20s
I'm 27. I'm almost 28. okay there she is
coming from a guy who's almost out of
his 20s
I don't know if y'all are around the
same age as me
but my 20s
sucked
the later the later half of my 20s have
been pretty good
like I've enjoyed it more than my
earlier twenties
much more
my early 20s were ass
now I'm now I'm I'm cool I'm I feel like
I'm having a good time
but before that
very fortunate
have you seen my companion Horus
to my shame I was snared by a trap and
we've become separated
not being able to find him since most
people I've talked to about that
they'll tell me the same thing that
they're like early 20s sucked and once
they get into their 30s stuff starts to
get a little better you know yes I see
Horus is a valiant night
you can look after himself no question
people are researching for me right now
with twice the resolve
where is Horus in the lake is he just
legit in the middle of the lake
and we'll lay prism stones to guide him
as always
please send him my word
of you
planes guide your way oh and then I
remember the other place we talked to
her it's like on that bridge that I
already broke yeah
[Music]
there's a little cave off to the side
that's right
all the memories are flooding back
okay Bloodhound step user Bloodhounds
Fang user
and you're annoying
um I cut this bone to a spot honestly I
don't know why I'm running this right
now
yeah [ __ ] this I don't know why I'm
running here
my 30s have been mediocre flipped the
car comma Cardiac Arrest losing use of
my dominant arm okay that all sounds
awful and I'm sorry
but that's like yeah that sounds bad
that sounds quite bad
okay now we need to go
here
Bloodhounds Fang with sleep grease
excellent
well that's cool bungalist
hopefully you're recovering
getting used to it
okay where where is horace's Little Lake
is it like this way
because I know I can go that way
okay metal
yes
that feels so good I love it
these games have made me enjoy pain
bro
foreign
how could you play these games without
enjoying pain
you are annoying little brat
there's Horus
why does Forest try to kill us
actually don't know the lore of this
no he went he went hollowed
really
what did he die to like did he just lose
it
because I smell bad
but I smell really good
foreign
he was a good man
until he gave up
like a loser-ass [ __ ]
imagine going Hollow couldn't be me
there's our large titanite shard another
large titanite shard
okay
so I don't want to tell Henry that I
killed him
foreign
there's a large type
um I feel like I should just run this
way honestly
to get the bonfire over here and then we
can come back
how far are we getting today
if I could hear myself think right now
um as far as I can
if we don't beat it today I think we can
beat it tomorrow
may take us another day after that to be
the
meeting
the Euros can't kill the worm
thank you
okay let's do this
you guys know the lore of this demon
it's kind of sad
I think his name's Old Demon King
foreign
what the [ __ ]
come on diving right into it
if we get them low enough health
[Music]
which I think my summon's just gonna
kill him which sucks now
[Music]
you'll like try to fight but he can't
bro
is there a way for me to unsummon
hopefully he just kills him
okay I didn't think not think that would
hit me
there we go cool
it's going crazy
do I think this is low enough
there he goes
what
he should be done oh he is done so he'll
keep trying but he just can't
[Music]
look at that dude
can barely move anymore
[Music]
can't even pick up his hammer
[Music]
but I'm out of his misery
this Edge
he does kind of look like
should have kissed him I didn't want to
kiss his face it's kind of gross
he was kind of gross I ain't even gonna
cap on a stack with you right now
again
I I hear blessing of
there we go
if you should acquire assistance
blessing of them okay
welcome home so I can level I'm pretty
sure I can upgrade my weapon as well
can you summarize the war of dark souls
in one sentence
let them assume a new master
inhabiting
the fire fades
that's pretty much it
right
the fire Fates essentially
[Music]
farewell I shouldn't one damn I got all
my [ __ ] I can't even upgrade now I
didn't you know
damn
gracious let other
yeah what can I sell because I gotta
sell some [ __ ] now
I've never used these pellets ever
not a single time
I'm not gonna use the Fire Gem
not gonna use the heavy gym
[Music]
I'm gonna need those
okay okay fashion one
[Music]
which is what
did you finish bloodborne yeah I did
I don't want to see my work squandered
heck yeah I did
okay
let us continue
I give the calendar this guy
probably
should just give it to him just so we
talk to him
where's Siegler oh that unkindled and a
seeker of Lords
I am bloodless of colon
look not in bewilderment as I say
I linked the fire long ago becoming the
Lord of Cinder
if substantiation be thy oh the
cathedral set thine eyes upon my
childhood calls
well that's not this yeah sad could
happen
no need to be called
have a closer look
you've killed oh but like it is we
already played Dark Souls on stream
Evelyn
there's a playlist if you want to watch
it but
transposition is the art of extracting
and coalescing the essence of a soul
in transposing a Twisted Soul it's true
power transferred to thee
thy purpose is to seek no I've never
tried Neo
what's to fear in a little transposition
and yes I love bloodborne Anton
love it love it
do not be away Over Law
[Music]
I don't have plans to play Hollow Knight
now
trying to think trying to think okay
I mean do I really care about sigrid's
armor I'm not gonna use it
never played Persona either
you like it better than Elden ring
personally yes I do
[Music]
for your arm fight oh that's what you're
talking about I thought you're talking
about
here or the
here where it's not really him it's
patches
trying to think of where to go
so do I talk to Henry in the place I
just found her or is she by the bridge
by walnir now
he should be by the bridge right
[Applause]
oh I have to buy armor from patches or
siegward oh so we can get him for yorm
gotcha
okay is there anything that kind of
putts that from happening like if I do
wall near here
will patches leave
when you get a Slappy boy too the bridge
what the [ __ ]
really I gotta go all the way around
again
I thought that bridge would have stayed
down dude damn it
that sucks
hello
foreign
like he's not even like real he's just
kind of there
he doesn't like yorm
I like Yorn I have a poster of yarn in
my room right above my head actually
and where can I go so that's
uh this is close
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
probably thinking of kingsfield
this patch is really in King's field
he gives us a gem we don't care about
Again by the way
okay let's go find
there she is right up there
enough
oh I have to go across got it
just so they don't follow
[ __ ] y'all skeletons bro
are you kidding me
are you kidding me dude where was the
way to go over here
hello it's literally right there
[Music]
hopefully it reloads when I do this
let's go mug good [ __ ]
never played armored Core is there
rumors of him making armor core again
[ __ ]
oh just
pain everywhere all right
use bonfire rest Lazarus
it's confirmed
was that with that leak where it said
like barbarians of the Badlands too
because I don't believe that thing for a
second
they were saying like little nightmares
three armored Core
wonder is easy pretty much always so I'm
not too worried about it
although I'm pretty sure they buffed him
foreign
was but is still pretty easy
how did I miss this I am blind
so blind
oh
ah hello
[Music]
have you seen Horus anywhere
okay are you guys sure I just say
nothing
I don't remember what to do here
specifically
don't tell her
you kidding me bro
he'll bury him
most of you guys are saying say nothing
oh yes I see
yeah I killed him
[Music]
[Music]
what's the point of not telling her
he's dead he went Hollow
well can I tell her now that we killed
her
or killed him
she goes Hollow if you tell her all
right I'm just not gonna tell her
gotcha
gotcha gotcha gotcha
all right let's fight one here
do I have to do siegward now
[ __ ] dude why
oh this is so annoying okay so that's
I have to go do the patches thing is
what you're saying
right
okay
well [ __ ] now I gotta man
oh I'm sorry Joy you're taking a nap and
I've been yelling all
I'm sorry it's okay
I don't know I we're not doing 100 I
just want to do the quest why not
I wouldn't spawn an earphone
is that where he never mind
I'm probably overthinking it okay so I
have to go
here
and then he's like on something up and
to the right
yeah Dark Souls 2 isn't connected Dark
Souls 3 is like thousands of years in
the Future Past Dark Souls 1.
if I'm pretty sure that's correct
what up D
foreign
[Music]
I I would play Dark Souls one and then
three yeah you can be dark souls one
pretty quick
this looks like Cathedral Ward
yeah it kind of does from bloodborne
it's right here guys
nah that ain't right
well you look reasonably sane
I am a knight of Katarina
I've managed to track down this
Cathedral store of treasure
it's right over there across that narrow
part
treasure
always so close
yet so far
I'm in quite a pickle indeed
now this sauce is [ __ ] hmm
can I just kill him or do I have to go
through his [ __ ]
or can I just fight him
well did you just hold your horses
I know I know
the gospel I knew something was wrong
it's patches boys
I'm unbreakable patches nobody can crack
me
you [ __ ]
why me why me because you're a clown bro
that's why you
dumbass
what do you think man
oh that should be the armor
yeah he knows why yay kid himself
believe this is where the Covenant is
patches is just a literal clown Behavior
straight up blown ass Behavior
sir
foreign
your Covenant little wormies
no now that I'm thinking about it is
this like
there are cribs everywhere is this like
Ronaldo
right like reminds me of Renault that's
the first thing I think of when I come
in here now
ooh the Thorns cool
should I join this Covenant
I don't really care
it's cool to be here though
okay
oh wait I can't travel from here he's so
bloodborne okay travel
so now that we have it
where what's next
for the
for the [ __ ] uh Quest
yeah they they draw inspiration from
each other for sure
I'll ask but I I won't give her a tongue
dude look this is where I can alter my
appearance I can reallocate attributes
what is up with that this it's literally
ranala I didn't even know you could do
that with her what the [ __ ] like
what is up with that
and like babies and kids and [ __ ]
just like Eldon ring wow
that's an interesting
definitely inspired here for sure
okay we'll go to the
we have to go here
Zoli did a whole video about this area
or the
the comparisons to Ronaldo
oh this is not the right spot
why is that
you did a comparison to Ronaldo really
cool
it's pretty clear yeah
[Applause]
oh he's in a well outside to the right I
got you
I'll go there first you guys are saying
won't here
holy [ __ ] we are lost as [ __ ]
there's some sus jars around there Tommy
shut up oh goddess
okay the Well's right here
yo
[Music]
anyone there
anyone at all
yeah
oh
I know that voice just how long has it
been like an hour
it's me secret of Katarina
I love to admit it but I've been had
someone's swiped my armor my armor
did you happen to see it anywhere
Joy is stretching drama's armor
what the [ __ ]
with mine yeah this is like the
Alexander of Dark Souls 3.
again
that seemed a little sus bro
no need to worry about me
with my trusty Suites
until we meet again
good friend
hahaha
yo why does it sound evil right there
what's up with that what's going on
okay now I can finally fight wolnir
I hope are you guys are gonna be like no
no no you got it
now be like full
okay
[Music]
I'll probably die to wool near
ly I think I'm kind of okay
right now
all right
damn I've already been streaming for
three hours what the [ __ ]
no shame in dying I I'm pretty sure he
has been buffed
but
we'll see
hello
ball
which one Ricky
you guys ready for some scary [ __ ]
that [ __ ] will kill me very quickly
eventually men are never seen him start
with that
foreign
I didn't even see I think I was too
close to him and he didn't spray it
that [ __ ] kills you
instantaneously bro damn
also Ricky we already went down there
and fought the boss
30 minutes ago
he's definitely been buffed for sure
I mean he was a joke before so I think a
buff makes sense but it is what it is
all right let's try that one again
that mist instas you though it's like
that you want him to back up to actually
look at the boss
otherwise you'd never see him
I don't know what he just did
looks like he's gonna crawl
what
what was that
sir I I can't hit your arm
[Music]
s
cool
foreign
I literally can't hit your arm
come on
foreign
dude
what the [ __ ] you see that
yeah he I don't know they buffed him by
making his last bracelet like ungiddable
for a while
which is like meh
who would you date in Dark Souls 3 your
mom
honor is pretty cool too
doors open
foreign
once you figure out madeira's movements
he's pretty easy otherwise he does take
a long time to beat no matter what
okay
you guys ready for
you got I bet everyone in here whether
you played the game or not we'll go
ooh
when you see the next area
[Music]
it kind of looks like yarnum
now that we just played bloodborne
everything looks like yarnum but like
wow
man
so cool
Harry Potter
I brought the doll there should be a bad
boy yep here we go
owie
bloodborne boss
they've got to be the best in the
business at exactly that Blockbuster
where they present a new area with a
beautiful view
we kind of start each level that way
it's like okay let's build off of this
View
like where they connect stuff
the ring is so good for your build I
think you're right
yeah
[Music]
moose attacks as long as tacking
persists yeah that's big
that's a big time bro all right we gotta
go back whoops some wrong spot back out
okay
I gotta fight the Pope
whoopsie
enjoys having a dream
he's very active today I need to take
her for a very long walk after strange
welcome home speak thine hearts desire d
he's being a cutie taking a little nap
I love my dog
I love my dog more than I love people
okay
I'm glad you like it Adam thanks for the
kind words
okay
um I ain't gonna lie I run through this
area as fast as I [ __ ] can for the
most part
because uh yeah
okay
here actually
will I Parry pontiff I know that's the
cool thing to do
but I'm not cool
yeah this is why I run
to that
[Applause]
foreign
that's how you get through there
one of the hardest areas in the game in
my opinion
running from one bonfire to the next
make sure to kill the Assassin in the
Church of Yorkshire
save Henry he's in the corner as a
statue oh wait you didn't do yule
we did do y'all
you talking here
foreign
[Music]
that's where we drop down from
our lady friend
oh he's right here wait that's ornery
Oh I thought it might be you
good to see you
I never managed to find Horus
protected my chat this dude you see that
an unkindled Lord Seeker
for the children I knew my chest is
speed rant
we all have our reasons don't we
please take this
foolish requests
and also a token of protection
May the Flames guide your way
ring of the evil eye
you are brave indeed
face your duty alone
I would do well to learn from you
May the Flames I am pretty cool aren't I
guys
May the Flames guide thee
staying there is somebody over here
huh you [ __ ]
why
why do you think
okay that sounded like a kid
literally sounded like a kid
ah I would do well to learn
okay
hey
[Music]
you won't let go
you won't let go
[Music]
stop yelling
you missed the fog wall
not yet
I have 2 000 hours in this game I just
don't know how to do certain quests
sometimes I don't remember how to do
quests but
where things are I usually remember
album
um
10 million Subs
foreign
next week
[Music]
I always found this like rock formation
to look kind of weird
it's like a bunch of bulges
okay we can go down to yorm unless do we
have to do something with Sig word first
second
or is he in here
somewhere
I won't go there yet
okay I can hit the bonfire though
okay
telling you dude I know how to play this
game for the most part
octave might be a struggle though he is
a actually an extremely difficult boss
although we can use summons outside
it is lit
we are lit
thank you
Sabian stopped spamming it's really
annoying
calm down
I don't know what just happened to me
but I don't like it
holy [ __ ]
I'm not like that at all
hmm
oh my God
oh oh
excuse me I
I must have dozed off
it's rather warm in here
well well hasn't it been all too long
it's good to see you oh I seem to have
missed my chance so
did I get lucky or did you just
overreact Sabian for my deepest
gratitude
I'm surprised to go with it
it's all yours
emit Force
I know won't you join me for dinner
I've got some stewing right now I saw
that even we are dead deserve a little
novelty from time to time and finally
upon this Rendezvous let us make a toast
my sword
and our sworn duties
long may the sun shine
yay
thanks man
have you heard
somewhere hidden right here in irafield
is a deep dungeon
and even below that
the profaned capital home of Yom
that inclusive giant load
that reminds me
I have a grave promised to keep
oh
sorry
I'm afraid I've cast a cloud over things
my poster above my head is literally of
yarn with Sigrid in front and he says
forgive me my friend to do really after
a nice toast
that's the quote under it forgive me my
friend
and he's asleep all right excellent
excellent
super stuff I said committed please let
me back
I mean if you got banned dude you got
banned like that that ain't no joke
foreign
I can't roll what the [ __ ] it wouldn't
let me roll at all
okay
I think I got staggered wow that guy
just annihilated my soul
they are Gwen's nights and I'm all the
way over [ __ ] here bro
yeah
I'm not gonna lie it's hard to get
banned from our Discord
so if you've got man
yikes
yeah I wasn't worried about the Archer I
didn't die in the Archer there
was just that guy
our boy's still asleep
oh
sorry
I mean yeah I'm gonna trust my mods dude
sorry
I don't know exactly what you did but
I'm gonna trust them they usually have
good judgment on that
[Music]
this is Dark Souls
foreign
large tits
[Music]
[Applause]
few large tits oh my God
um if you want freeze
I think you well actually you're not in
the display now
I was gonna say
if you message one of the mods
if you can I'm not sure if you can
ah
man I don't know what's
it inside them
I ban Bots and that's pretty much it
but it's pretty hard to get banned
oh don't pull that Justice we don't know
thanks pickle welcome
now don't do what freeze did
whatever that is
where's my elevator man give me the hell
out of here
all I have to do is open the door please
thank God
[Music]
[ __ ] dogs dude
all I had to do was open the door all is
well
who Let The Dogs Out
that
happened
we'll all take accountability
[Applause]
no it's okay you can hang out here and
try and not get banned here
that is language I don't speak or know
how to read
where are my Souls at bro
there they are
I think it's Arabic
see I don't know what
from software has against dogs they seem
to not like dogs
from what I'm seeing here
I'm almost dead
I tried to jump attack
these guys look so freaky
nice
I gotta be embered for the uh
these gonads here huh
there we go
I want to use Henry pretty much anywhere
I can who's this
oh he's that wizard dude I'm just gonna
use ornery
it's for the aesthetic
is there another gate I have to open
down there
foreign
oh it's just right in here okay
I couldn't remember exactly where this
was no Henry go back upstairs
Audrey
okay he's a he's a how is he not a
wizard
Henry get your ass up here
I'll try this with three flasks [ __ ] it
[Music]
he's not gonna do the attack
I was gonna try a Perry
[Music]
[Music]
always attacks are [ __ ] hard
he is insanely fast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I'm gonna die here guys
foreign
[Music]
yeah as I'm fighting him I'm like oh I
need to roll to the side not back
[Applause]
for sure for sure
will there be more Elden ring streams I
haven't played eldering in like two
weeks almost
I haven't even looked at it
well yeah like 10 days or something like
that
I try without a summon
foreign
you saw that
that happened
you saw that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
literally easier without a summon
God gamer
God gamer came out there
wait let me get these upgrades out here
real quick
so there's a couple of twinkie boys here
let's go
some twinkling bullies
are you kidding me all right
well let's go back
I don't think I need those yet
let's go upgrade and see if we do
I mean I thought if you hit them they
don't disappear
like what the hell
all right
yeah that's a PVP area
Joy is so cute because she's sleepy yeah
I don't know why I thought I could beat
this game in a day because it's just not
gonna happen
I've been kind of
I mean as a speed like how I used to
speedrun this game definitely way slower
like we've been listening in dialogue
doing quests and [ __ ]
makes sense
we'll play it for a few days
I'll take it slow
oh
let's do this first
one
it's definitely not slow either like we
are flying through the game to be honest
with you right now
okay now we need chunky boys
okay
I feel like my endurance is kind of low
four levels
one two one two
uh well actually one Joy gets all the
tummy Rose
[Music]
if we get to a hundred thousand Subs she
gets a hundred thousand tummy whoops
because she's such a sweetie
okay
the next place we can go let's go beat
yorm and then I think I have to call it
a day
because I'm the only one home right now
and the dogs are my responsibility
[Music]
let's go beat your
prefer Dark Souls 3 or bloodborne
I think I prefer at this point
bloodborne
we already rescued siegward
foreign
we're close to 100K aren't we I don't
really check what we're at very often
I don't mean to get those couple things
at Costco 30 pants Oh yes please
sorry it wasn't
now you rescue him in the cell in the
dungeon
in the jail is he is there a jail here
yeah I think I prefer bloodborne's
combat system
the war the level design in the world in
this game is awesome but I think
bloodborne is just like on another level
bro it's so good
wait there's a dungeon in irithyll
wait that's right down here
I don't remember sick we're being
trapped in here at all
I get a slab reward
we already met him in the kitchen
oh [ __ ]
we already met him in the kitchen
oh you spawn up there
crossbow
damn Bloodhound Spang huh
okay so I gotta go to the Basilisk
here
won't play bloodborne so bad I mean I
bought a PS4 to play bloodborne back in
the day
you guys are all over the place with
what you're telling me right now now I'm
just confused
this is the weight of the Basilisk if I
go through here right
yo these guys can [ __ ]
you'll get the key in the dungeon then
why why am I here
is the giant crossbow not called the
Basilisk or am I just
thinking of something else probably
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
I just got burned bro feels bad
hey
foreign
[Applause]
night scale
stop squeaking at me bro
sounding like a goddamn forehead
yeah I don't remember where cigarette is
down here at all
not even a little bit
[Music]
I think I've done this quest one time in
2000 hours
this we're getting an Estus shard
[Music]
so he's down here
hey yo what up
is he in there
what does Estes taste like what do you
get what do you think Estes is
this isn't poison I'm trying to remember
what the poison area is uh it's bottled
fire so probably hot probably a little
spicy
another mimic
really tried to get me here
lore video on Estes already been done
why did I not grab this
so probably just a really spicy soda
I always thought of it as like an orange
Fanta
yeah it's bottled fire which you get
from the bonfire
that's why it refills every time you go
there
you know what I'm saying
makes sense when you think about it
they all seem scary and I don't like
them
I already went that way
oh God damn it
ah
damn hello everyone
yeah it's like a Baja Blast I think
get it with the five dollar uh box at
Taco Bell
dude Joy looked up at me like what the
[ __ ] are you saying dude
okay do I drop down there or here
Joy hello
were you taking a Nappers
you don't like that Sam
yeah like a sunny day a Sunny D sunny
day
okay okay
that goes back over there I'm assuming
here then
hey yo what's going on here cup
who in here bro
guys nobody's here
did I kill the giant
foreign
do I have to kill the giant
D the bridge
that's where we just were guys like what
y'all were telling me not to go that way
foreign
this is where we've been bro what are
you guys talking about
oh man
[Applause]
it's literally this right here
oh wait not here
[Applause]
I mean whatever that was to never happen
again
foreign
okay maybe I'm dumb but I did not see
another way
a small room with two giant rats I know
exactly where that is it's just past the
[ __ ] Bridge
it's a where I could have been 10
minutes ago if I just did this
nothing here
nothing
dropping down
go across the bridge
in here
okay so you're saying there's another
way
holy [ __ ] you guys are so confusing
don't make any sense
[Applause]
thank you
what else am I reading Oscar you
forehead
[Applause]
hello why not just say go all the way to
the back of the tunnel
foreign
that is not what you guys were saying in
the complete
opposite areas like here's where I got
confused dude just to make me not sound
like a [ __ ] idiot here I was down
here 15 minutes ago and y'all made me go
up and around and over there and [ __ ]
like up into that cage it's like I
jumped down here 10 minutes before that
why'd you make me go in a [ __ ] Circle
okay now that I got that out of my
system where does the key go
whatever
there's a door where the rats are
I don't see a [ __ ] door
dog there ain't no [ __ ] door in here
bro I'm gonna I'm gonna poop my pants
I'm literally gonna poop
the profane Capital now
and that
okay
did I need the key to go there
I think that's where I'm getting
confused because I'm like no you don't
need a key
I need a key to help siegward
okay
okay
yeah sakiro did win the boat I wanted to
play Dark Souls 3.
okay
can you guys tell me where around here
is sigrid's cell because you guys are
making me think it was back there
oh it's down the swamp from here don't
poop I'm gonna poop Jared it's gonna
happen I'm going to [ __ ] my pants
and y'all are gonna go ew
what the [ __ ]
the vote was pointless yes
your vote was pointless
and thank you Jared for the five dollars
I appreciate it
y'all thought this was a democracy
it's not
this is my [ __ ] Channel
I can do what I want
I did want your opinion though and I got
it
and then I chose to ignore it
welcome to Jake Rock
y
am I missing uh something probably
what's [ __ ] new
I've played too much Elden ring to give
a [ __ ] about these guys
I would start at Dark Souls 1 Adam and
then play Dark Souls 3.
I would um if you have Dark Souls 2
um you could use that as potentially
a
you know a paperweight
maybe even a poster of some kind you
could do that with it
um anything other than play it is my
recommendation
Bots
am I going the right way
answers probably nope
you could trade it for the Space Jam DVD
I like that
that's good advice
okay that's the bridge to yorm
I swear there's like a lower area right
even lower
isn't there like creepy ass babies
oh I do have to drop in the hole okay
I thought it'd be like just a penalty
holy
foreign
boys
Miyazaki in your goddamn swamps
oh my God
oh there's a ladder and I am blind
foreign
there's a reason I didn't [ __ ] do
this [ __ ]
I may have been to this area once
in 2000 hours
yep weird babies
I am getting a little irritable you
could say that
foreign
I just wanna see what's up here
where is this
nice
why is that bobbling
this looks way better than when I play
it with my TV
ah
why are you here
where did you come from
this is not good guys do I have
um
a little little pus a little nope I sure
don't all right
I think I'm just dead like I die
foreign
well
we'll come back and uh try that again
yeah I should have homewarded it
she did a bonered out
sorry
rip 14k true
reverse flash I think uh sakiro is
easily the hardest of all of these games
Dark Souls 3 is
quite easy
imperatively Dark Souls 1 is really easy
now
sideways please
going in here
foreign
I don't know what that is
so there's a mage up here or wait where
was that
it's like over here
I'm so lost
up here
all right where are you
[Music]
okay okay
hi Joy
thank you
Joy would like to leave
okay his Poise is nuts
okay
sorry Joey wanted to leave the room
opening in the wall and you're there
Wrath of the Gods
aren't these things like horrifying
yep
foreign
oh I'm dead
why does poison linger so long
holy [ __ ]
I'm just out of here
why you guys saying the wrong the wrong
hole in the wall
[Music]
what are you talking about
there's a hole in the wall and I went
through the hole in the wall
you're saying there's another hole in
the wall
farewell I shouldn't one
there's a window to jump into
bro I'm a poop
it's gonna happen Chad
with this direction
from y'all
I'm gonna poop
[Music]
by anti-toxic items
foreign
[Music]
that's for the weak sauce
you know what I do with poison I tank it
you need the old rusty key that we
already
you know it would be a lot easier for me
to get purple Moss clumps
guess what I'm not gonna do
exactly that okay maybe this will be
better nope this was obnoxiously worse
area to fall into
[Music]
there's a window by the stairs where you
fought the mage
okay
I'm going to that
not here
because y'all yelled at me
I went through here and y'all yelled at
me
like why are you saying window if you're
talking about this
this here is this a window to you
anyway
look at oh my God
I am gonna poop
you gotta Jump The Gap
come on out you fat [ __ ]
ah you are a saint
once again you are my Valiant savior
Isaac vet of Katarina express my deepest
gratitude that did look like a window
a token of my facts
go on
ah no please go on ahead
of my own road to take and a duty to
fulfill
very soon I'm gonna ask something okay
oh no and we go fight yorm now
okay
gosh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
man
you're saying sigvert is the dung eater
is like saying a dog is a cat
are you only six Estes
because I want to
ain't got no reason
[Applause]
other than I don't [ __ ] no
I don't know
I don't know
what is cat dog a fake show on
Nickelodeon
badass
yum
old friend
hi
secret of the Knights of Katarina
have come to uphold my promise
that the sun shine upon this Lord of
Cinder
I want to see all these people before
they went nuts
before they went nuts
distract them buddy I gotta go over here
can he solo him chat
let's watch
let's go Sigmar
[Music]
how do you know what
did he already die
foreign
will he come back
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so he legit just gets [ __ ]
like what if what if you weren't there
for this
what what if you weren't here
well there we go
so he's just dead
foreign
man
they really just said yeah if you want
to do this Quest
you [ __ ] up the quests at all
he's dead
well I'm glad we did two hours of extra
work
for him to just
hi
I mean I thought he could solo him it
was like his thing you know I don't
think that was too far of a weird
stretch
oh my God
he's he's actually dead
so is he just a failure
foreign
you cannot put all this on me guys
no shot
we will avenge him
you weren't my friend
and he was yours
oh power through it baby
[Music]
foreign
what
[Applause]
what Emerald
[Music]
Force
I missed
for my friend
sir onion head
I'll miss you buddy
in his honor
foreign
yes
yes for him
you know what I'm gonna do
I
I'm Gonna Leave
why can't I do that here
huh
I want to leave a [ __ ] here
all right whatever never mind I'm not
gonna do it
I was gonna leave a stop there in his
honor
but that's proving to be too much work
for me apparently so
goodbye
[Laughter]
GG guys
GG
he may be dead
but
we honored his death
we won't talk about me toasting and
sitting in the corner while he fought a
giant by himself
very well then
14k Souls is like nothing to me
oh well yeah I have an Estus
foreign
[Music]
excellent
still need a chunk but we gotta slam
all right family
that's all I got in me today we did not
get anywhere close speed in the game but
we'll come back tomorrow same time we'll
continue where we left off we're gonna
do all the DLCs everything so
we'll probably be playing this game this
week and then we'll pick up Sakira
thanks for all the support today I
appreciate every single one of you
thanks for watching thanks for helping
even you know
as bad as your directions may be or as
bad as my listening skills Maybe
I still appreciate you guys
[Music]
but have a great rest of your day have a
great night eat some good food drink
some water and we'll be back tomorrow
all right
peace and love
I'll see y'all soon
peace out bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye
[Music]